the US has announced we will be
deploying more troops to the Middle East
we've already got a large uh a large
amount 19,000 Personnel already in the
Mediterranean we've got another 2,000
marines that are poised to go and the
Pentagon is saying 900 more troops have
already deployed are or are deploying so
I hope youall are ready for what's to
come Israel previously agreed to delay
their invasion of Gaza to allow the US
to prepare missile batteries Patriot
missile uh Patriot missile and th
missile systems and now we've got report
Israel has invaded Gaza so I hope you're
ready for what comes next now
interestingly the official reporting is
saying no no they have not yet invaded
Gaza they've just sent a bunch of tanks
in to start targeting Hamas targets and
killing Hamas Leaders with tanks in Gaza
so so the tanks are going in but it's
not an invasion and I'm just like yo if
having a bunch of Tanks go into this
territory and kill people is not an
invasion then what's happening on the
southern border is not an invasion okay
yeah this is what's happening